what I want to do in this video is to
talk a little bit about 401ks which you
probably at minimum have heard of and
just from the get-go just to put some
structure in your mind of what this
really is is it's very similar to a
traditional IRA so it's very similar
very similar to a traditional IRA
traditional IRA and the ways that
they're the same is that you defer your
taxes so you put money in on a
tax-deferred basis so you put money let
me put it this way you put untaxed or
you put pre-tax money in you put tree
pre-tax money in money in the money can
grow inside of either the 401k account
or the traditional IRA K aw IRA account
untaxed let me write that money money
grows an account in account untaxed
untaxed and then you can withdraw it you
can withdraw the money you can withdraw
can withdraw or start getting
distributions from the account after
after age after age fifty nine and a
half so that's essentially when you're
gonna start retiring when you're gonna
need the money and when you withdraw
after the age of fifty nine and a half
you will then pay income tax you will
then pay income tax then pay then pay
income tax and this is what people are
talking about when they talk about
deferring taxes you're not getting out
of the taxes you're just pushing off the
date that you're going to have to pay
the taxes and for a lot of people this
might be useful because while you are
making money you might be paying at a
fairly high incremental tax rate but
then once you're retired you have a much
lower you'll have a much lower one I
guess you'll be in a much lower
incremental tax bracket and so your
total overall tax bill might be lower
also maybe something happens
in terms of what the government does in
terms of how they charge taxes and in
general if you had to pay 50 cents 20
years in the future versus 50 cents
today just present value of money tells
you that the that 50 cents is going to
be worth a lot less in the future or
that it or the present value of it is a
lot less so that's what some reasons to
defer but of course you're you're not
paying you're not just going to pay on
what you put in
you will then also pay income tax on
what you put in and whatever grew so you
will pay income tax on total on total
total dispersals this Bert Versalles and
in both cases you have to start taking
disbursements from your account by 70
and a half so penalties penalties let me
write it this way penalties penalties if
you don't withdraw if you don't withdraw
or you don't start withdrawing some of
your funds by 70 and a half and there's
some special cases if you're working and
all these type of things now what
happens if you would draw before age 59
and a half so before 59 and a half
before 59 and a half so so far these
everything I've listed is true of both
401ks and traditional IRAs
if you withdraw before 59 and a half you
are taxed taxed on withdrawal with drawl
and on top of that you get it there's a
10% penalty on all the funds you receive
10% penalty 10% penalty and this is what
you have to think about it unless you
know if you just say oh I'm just always
gonna max out my traditional IRA or 401k
you got to make sure they're not gonna
want that money before fifteen nine and
a half because you might be facing this
10% withdrawal so these are all the
cases that they're the same so the
question is why do they both exist why
is there something called a traditional
IRA and why is there something called a
401k they both seem like a pretty good
way for me to defer taxes pay get it get
earrings on on on income in a taxed or
on my investment in a tax deferred way
and then paid some future date and
most kind of forced me to make sure they
strongly suggest that I shouldn't take
out my money before fifty nine and a
half so the ways that they're different
so let's focus on the differences so the
difference is between the two the
difference is the difference is between
the two one is for one case have a
higher limit 401ks
have higher limit have higher limit and
if you if you're focused on 2010 but
these numbers keep changing but in 2010
the 401k limit is sixteen thousand five
hundred dollars and that's for just what
you contribute into your 401k while the
IRA so this is for a 401k 401k while the
IRA limit the IRA limit is five thousand
dollars this is an IRA
so one 401k you can just participate
with more money and actually in both of
these cases as you approach your
retirement so after the age of fifty so
let me put that in the same thing just
so we're comprehensive so another
similarity is that you can have higher
you can accelerate some of your so you
can accelerate or have higher you can
have higher I guess deposits into your
into your account accelerate after after
fifty which just means you can put more
money than these limits that I have
right here so these are your limits
before you're fifty after fifty between
fifty and fifty nine and a half when you
can start withdrawing you can put a
little bit more money and then these are
constantly moving targets but the
general idea is that you can put more
money win a four in it's inside of a 401
K now the other difference is that a 401
K tends to be organized by your employer
401 K organized by employer organized by
employer and just from your point of
view that means two things one is the
employer will often specify the
potential investments specify specifies
investments investments
so they'll actually run they'll actually
run the 401k account for you normally
will be held by someone else but it will
be for your company for company X and
the company gets to decide the universe
of investments that you might be able to
invest in and the other thing because
it's run by the employer because the
employer might match employer employer
might match might match which means for
every dollar you put in they'll put
another dollar or even they might go
above matching and you can actually go
up to I think the current limits are
approaching $50,000 for the total of the
employee and employee and employer match
so you can actually get a lot of I guess
you could think of it leverage from
putting in into a 401k if you have a
very generous employer and the other
difference and this is really kind of a
superficial difference because it's just
what you see is that with the 401k the
money will be taken out of your paycheck
you will never see it so taken out
before paycheck take in out before
paycheck while with a traditional IRA
you will take the money invest it into a
traditional IRA account when you report
your taxes it'll be reported as a tax
deduction and so you won't have to pay
taxes on it functionally they're the
exact same thing so you think about the
pros and cons if you have a 401k if the
option is available to you it's a pretty
good option you're gonna have higher
limit you're going to have a higher
limit right over here and your employer
might match it and your employer might
match it and then the other thing and
this doesn't come into place a lot but
there's also the option of borrowing
from a 401k without penalty borrowing
borrowing from from a 401k but you have
to pay back interest to the 401k account
if you did that and you cannot do that
with a traditional IRA now when you're
looking at all this so like what why
would anyone ever want to do a
traditional IRA well there's a couple of
things one you could do both or the
other thing is with traditional IRAs you
are you have much more flexibility on
where you want to invest maybe your
company says you can only invest in us
you can only invest in that company
stock 1 a traditional IRAs and a
traditional IRA
you can invest in anything but hopefully
that clarifies things a bit for you